I agree for some channels like it's it's
very strong and it it's very um it's
very specific like to different
audiences or different platforms. Some
people just like video. I go back to the
success signals of a lot of platforms
are measuring how long you're watching
the video for and the time and like how
many people completed it, like the
completion rate. And um I always tell
people, you know, that doesn't mean you
have to stay away from long form. you.
It just means however long your video
is, like every second you add has to be
more seconds of value. Um, because if
you make it really long, but you put all
the value in the first 5 seconds, then
people aren't going to watch it and then
your video is not going to be served.
So, I think when it comes to video, you
have to be really strategic in the
message you're getting across and how
that message correlates to how long the
video is. Um, I personally am, at least
on, you know, some platforms like
LinkedIn or Instagram, I'm a big fan of
carousels. And I know that video is
really hot right now, but carousels are
really important because one of the
things that are measured as a success
signal is the time spent on the post.
So, you see an image, you kind of get
the image just like that. But if you
post a carousel that has, you know,
five, six, seven, up to 10 or 12 slides,
that's so much time someone is spending
on the post reading the text in the
post, clicking on to the next slide, so
on and so forth. And then that makes the
success signals increase and that will
push your post to more people. So I am
for video. I think video is really
impactful. It brings things to life.
That's why influencers have had such a
big boom.
Lauren, thank you so much for joining me
from San Diego. How are you?
>> I'm doing great. Thank you so much for
having me here today.
>> Wonderful to have you. H so you you have
a really interesting position, a really
interesting company because Canva is a
really unique company in the landscape.
Erh uh it's unique in terms of its
leadership with an incredible CEO uh
driving this company into a world of
empowering pretty much anybody to create
creatives that until you know a few
years ago you wouldn't really need to
hire a Photoshop professional to do. And
what's really cool about the company is
that it's also really adapting to the to
the advancing AI landscape. And so it's
so cool and and with that you have a
brand and a persona that is very um
engaging and it's it's very approachable
and that's where you come in because you
lead social media and influencers at
Canva.
>> Yes. Yes. I am so lucky to be working at
Canva. Everything you said is spoton. We
are all about empowerment and luckily we
I always say this as someone who has
worked in social and worked at previous
companies in social, the luckiest thing
is to have fans and followers who are
like the biggest fans and the biggest
advocates for your company or for your
product or service. And at Canva, we
definitely have that. And it's one of my
favorite parts of working there is just
to see the passion from the people who
use our product and the people who
follow us on social. Um, and so I've
I've gotten to work on social there for
three and a half years now. And I also
lead our B2B influencers and our higher
education influencers. And it's so easy
to work with them because they have so
much passion for our product. And
exactly what you said, like not only
does it empower people, but it also
gives people so many opportunities if
they can't afford an entire creative
team or, you know, like so many
different teams that would cost so much
money. If you're just starting out or
you're a oneman show, like Canva just
gives you the ability to do so many
things and take whatever your vision is
for your personal brand or a company
that you started to just new heights.
So, I'm very lucky to work there and um
I am really really excited to see what
they do next.
>> You touched on a few super interesting
subjects. There's the fans are are
incredibly engaging and they really are
fans of of the product. you know, when
you have followers, I'm sure it's hard
to, you don't always know whether it's a
follower that's a, you know, a fan or
medium fan or doesn't really care, but
wants to see our posts. I think also
what's what's unique here is that the
the product is intended for pe creative
people to do their creative things. So
it's not like you're uh promoting a a in
a B2B influencer type, you know, a
product that has one use case and you're
asking influencers to hold it up and to
drink it or to do. Not that I have
anything against drinking brands, but
but you can actually, you know, the
lengths at which you can get creative
with these influencers. I'm sure it's
pretty pretty wild, right? It is exactly
like because we have not just so many
tools but tools can be used in so many
different ways. It makes my job easier
and I think it makes the content just so
much more interesting for everyone. So
when you work with an influencer and you
want them to, you know, just partner
with you. They have so many different
things to choose from and they have so
many different point of views that they
can share it. you mentioned, you know,
it is so great for creative people, but
Canvas is also great for people who
aren't creative and they like don't know
what to do and they need inspiration and
they're like, how how do I create a
social post or how do I create an
engaging deck presentation to like show
investors or whatever it may be. Um, so
I think that's really cool that it it's
it is for the creative crowd and the
people with those amazing ideas, but
it's also for the people who think, "Oh,
I don't know if I'm that creative or I
don't know if I can make something very
engaging." That's where Canva comes in.
And I think that's really where it just
allows people to level up. And um, when
we work with influencers, it's so
interesting to hear their point of view
or like to hear their concepts when we
work with them because I think, "Oh my
god, I never would have thought of that.
I didn't know that you would use it for
this or I didn't know that you use this
tool in your workflow. I've worked with
some B2B influencers who work on the
sales side and I have never worked in
sales in my career ever. So, it's really
cool to hear their perspective and hear
what they use the tools for because it's
some things that I never would have
thought of and that's one of the most
important reasons of using influencers
because they can touch all these areas
that I don't have knowledge on and I
don't know how to connect with that
audience with
Incredible. What is, you know, just an
example of a a way that you've worked
with an influencer
>> to uh, you know, to to show the the
awesomeness of Canva here.
>> Yeah. Um, one of my favorites that we
just we just worked with Eileen Quac who
uh works at Hootswuite. Um, she is a B2B
influencer
and um, we worked with her on a camera
partnership to show sheets. So we have
canvas sheets now which are like
spreadsheets and it was really amazing
for her to share from her perspective as
a social media manager who's not very uh
well-versed in numbers and data and
things like that but she needs to show
the impact of her work of her social
work. So, it was really cool for her to
show how she uses sheets as like a
nonanalytical person to still help um
push forward her impact in her job and
make sure that all of the social asks
that she needs, whether it be budget or
new ideas or whatever, like gets through
to people. So, that was a really cool
one that we recently worked on. And how
how is the actual flow working when you
when you want to engage with with
influencers to drive the message
forward? I think that's such an amazing
way for brands to engage in an organic
and an authentic way. Um what how does
that process actually work?
>> Yeah. So um start to finish, you know,
we search for influencers that we
believe have a very engaged audience.
Now, I think like some outdated point of
views for influencers or like how many
followers do they have? Like do they
have tens of thousands, things like
that. Um, but I think now now more than
ever people are realizing that it's not
about the number, it's about relevance
and it's about the engagement that they
have. So, you know, maybe this person
only has 5,000 followers, but whenever
they post something, they get 500 likes
and 500 comments. you know, like
something really really strong
engagement and that's what we care about
most. I think what people often forget
is the messenger is just as important as
the message. So when you work with
influencers, you have to be really
really like clear on who you're picking
to carry the message because you can
always choose the person with the
biggest following. you can pay millions
or whatever to get them to speak about
your product, but kind of like what you
were saying before of those drink brands
of like just holding it up, look at me.
That's not really resonating with
people. Like you need to find a
messenger to carry the message. So when
we look for influencers, we really try
to see, you know, can this per does this
person have a background um whether it
be their career background or the
background in the type of content that
they post and the subjects that they
speak about like to to really carry our
message in an impactful way. So we look
for that. Um first and foremost, I guess
if you're looking for a KPI, we look for
the engagement. Um, from there we reach
out to them just very clearly like we
want to work on XYZ, here's a brief just
so they can like get the overview. We
ask for their rates and then from there
we drop an agreement and then we go back
and forth on some feedback after they
give us concepts or drafts. Um, and then
it goes live. And so far it's been
working really well. Um, and I think the
number one thing to always remember in
the influencer world is they know their
audience best and it's their voice that
you're essentially borrowing. Um, so
whenever I'm working with influencers or
even giving feedback, I always make sure
that any feedback I give is just really
rooted in like the CTA or the objective.
It's not rooted in, oh, this was kind of
a weird sentence or like I don't know
about this point of view uh point of
view because that's their voice. You
know what I mean? Um, so that's kind of
the overview of how we work with
influencers and it's been really
impactful so far.
>> Wow. It sounds like there's a lot of um
nuance in making it be natural and
organic, not for the sake of being
authentic, but because it drives better
results. And um, and it's I guess that's
why also you mentioned that it's
important to be able to listen to your
influencer because they know their
audience best. I assume that's also a
good way to screen whether that
influencer is a good fit. Um because you
you want to I guess to target the right
audience and that leads me to another
area that I think is really important
here which is how do you drive insights
and how do you actually know what is the
right message to to talk about? What is
the right tone? What is the right you
know erh
product features to actually talk about
that your audience will care. I assume
it's a complicated process, but I mean,
you have so many followers, there's so
many influencers.
How can you create a feedback loop that
drives your next decisions?
>> Yeah, that's a great question. Um, it's
a lot to think about and it's a lot to
take all these things into account to
exactly what you said, create insights
and be like, okay, how are we going to
move forward from here? I think um both
working with influencers and then just
working on social content that comes
from the company's own brands, it first
and foremost starts with the purpose of
like why are you sharing? Um and I know
that sounds really simple, but so many
brands just assume that they should be
on social and they assume that they
should be posting every single little
thing and that's not true. As a social
media manager, I can tell you like you
don't need to post everything. You don't
need to be on every platform. Um it's
not just unnecessary but it's
unstrategic. Uh one really important
question I always ask myself whether I'm
working on content with influencers or
from the brand channels is the idea of
why share why care. Why are you sharing
this content from a brand perspective?
Like why does your company care to share
this? And then the uh why care is just
like why is your audience going to care?
How is it going to resonate with them?
Is it entertaining? Is it informational?
like how is this going to move the
needle for them? And once you can
overlap the why share why care and you
have a really strong understanding of my
company is sharing this because it's
disrupting the space and people are
going to care about it because we are
communicating it in a way that solves a
common problem. That's where you start
off. Um and then from there I like to
make sure that I'm like bucketing out
okay I understand why I'm sharing it. I
need the what. Am I trying to do this to
grow my audience? Am I trying to do it
to engage them? Am I trying to do it to
retain the audience I already have?
Because I don't want to forget about my
fans. A lot of people focus on growth,
but not a lot of companies are focusing
on, okay, you already have like a loyal
fan base. Let's not forget about them.
Um, so I think about those things. And
then from there, I think we already
talked about this like the messenger,
should it go through the branch channels
or the influencer or even, you know,
somewhere else? Maybe it can come from
an internal expert like the CMO or
something. Anyways, um and then I use
the insights that platforms have given
us of what performs best. So for example
uh every brand channel or every uh
social media channel has what I call
like success signals. So for example
Instagram uh their su their success
signal try to say that five times fast.
Um their success signal is shares and
saves. So whenever I post on Instagram I
think okay is this content sharable or
and is it savable? And if it's neither
of those things then Instagram's
probably not the best place for it. So
to answer your question of like how do
we you know test and learn and get the
insights to uh iterate and make sure
we're always coming out with impactful
uh content for the future. It's really
about testing and learning and using the
information that we have at hand to make
smart decisions and sometimes they don't
pan out. Sometimes we can do everything
right and then we post it and it flops.
But every every time we do it, we're
learning and we're always looking at our
analytics of like did it hit benchmarks?
Did it exceed benchmarks so much that we
need to dive into this and be like,
okay, what was the secret sauce of this
because it just blew up. Um, so that's
that's kind of the process that I always
like to take.
>> Amazing. And I guess a lot of the tools
and in general the world is moving a lot
from traditional media in textbased
format or image format. Now we have
social video and
>> I think the last last statistic I saw is
maybe 25%
of luxury purchases are happening over
social video. Something that blew my
mind
because that immediately made me think
as as a you know as a computer science
guy. It made me think, wow, I wonder if
we're really making use of all these
amazing nuances and insights that that
videos now bring because an image is
worth a thousand words, right? We know
that. Uh so it's not as simple as
tracking, you know, was this post
successful or not. It's wow, there's now
so many parameters which could have
impacted it. How do you look at the
growth and rise of social video in the
context of your work?
>> Yeah, that's a good question. It's so
interesting because I feel like video
is, you know, the new popular girl and
um everyone's everyone's putting so much
focus on it and I agree for some
channels like it's it's very strong and
it it's very um it's very specific like
to different audiences or different
platforms. Some people just like video.
I go back to the success signals of a
lot of platforms are measuring how long
you're watching the video for and the
time and like how many people completed
it, like the completion rate. And um I
always tell people, you know, that
doesn't mean you have to stay away from
long form. You it just means however
long your video is, like every second
you add has to be more seconds of value.
Um because if you make it really long
but you put all the value in the first 5
seconds, then people aren't going to
watch it and then your video is not
going to be served. So I think when it
comes to video, you have to be really
strategic in the message you're getting
across and how that message correlates
to how long the video is. Um, I
personally am, at least on, you know,
some platforms like LinkedIn or
Instagram, I'm a big fan of carousels.
And I know that video is really hot
right now, but carousels are really
important because one of the things that
are measured as a success signal is the
time spent on the post. So, you see an
image, you kind of get the image just
like that. But if you post a carousel
that has, you know, five, six, seven up
to 10 or 12 slides, that's so much time
someone is spending on the post reading
the text in the post, clicking on to the
next slide, so on and so forth. And then
that makes the success signals increase
and that will push your post to more
people. So I am for video. I think video
is really impactful. It brings things to
life. That's why influencers have had
such a big boom. I think video really um
resonates with people. However, I don't
think that means that we have to get rid
of static. I think that it just needs to
evolve. And I think that evolution that
we've seen has been from one static
image to a carousel. Um so that's that's
my whole view on it. But I I'm pro
video, but I'm also pro let's just
evolve statics to be more interesting.
>> Wow. Well, Lauren, I I want you to leave
us with a thought on, you know, what
what really gets you excited in in this
work that you do? you've been doing this
work for some time and and I see in
different contexts with different
companies and and but but but I think
you're you're in such an incredible
position now to um to to be at the
forefront of what it means to lead
social media and and influencers because
obviously most companies have that
position but I but I imagine in a
company like Canva it's it really is you
know at the cutting edge. So, you know,
share with me what what really gets you
excited about this.
>> Yeah. I mean, what gets me most excited
about my current job is that this is my
dream company. Um, that's just the
truth. I've been a fan of this company
for so long. So, to have lived so much
of my life as a customer and a viewer
and now get to be on the other side of
it and speak to our customers and
viewers just like how I would have
wanted to be spoken to is really cool.
It's a very special full circle moment.
So I think being able to work for a
brand that you truly believe in is what
makes me so passionate. And then the
second big thing for me is what got me
into social in the first place like
outside of all the companies that I've
worked for is that social is so ever
changing. I mean there are so many
different platforms and changes in the
platforms and the ways we connect with
each other is just constantly constantly
evolving. Um, so I always wanted to be a
part of that and um, a nice connection
to that is the world that we're in right
now with like AI that's ever changing as
well and that's impacting how we work
every day, but also like in social media
specifically. So I think being able to
work at a company that is so innovative
makes me really passionate.
>> I love it. Lauren, thank you so much.
Really appreciate your time and the
energy you've brought to this and uh,
for sharing your excitement with me. So
thank you so much for being here.
>> Yeah, thank you so much for having me.
Amazing.